nasty so crunchy a little chewy it
tastes ugly
it's soggy
excuse me
yeah
you wanna eat come on enjoy it and have
fun i love cooking it's part of my life
so every day i cook for my family i
think good lumpia first off should taste
like authentic filipino it should be
bite-sized and at the same time should
be crispy and golden brown if you are
not seeing those three things then it's
not lump young shanghai everyone has
different tastes don't make it in
neutral they can add more you know
ingredients if they want they want it
salty spicy or sweet all right i'm
hungry let's do this okay
this looks good now i'm ready to dig in
maybe you can dip it in the sauce it
much better here you go taste it
mmm
that's good crunchy it's looking a
little pale for my taste it looks like
it's been wrapped perfect someone's got
skills
um
i don't know
it's soggy
a little chewy
where's the umami what's the salt i
don't know maybe i just like it a little
salty i'm salty this very salt is good
because it's not salty and it's not
spicy and you can dip it in a sauce if
you want it much better or you want it
saltier or you want it spicy the olympia
is not burned
it's really cooked and the
wrap is cooked well i get hungry already
i've only had one bite and it's already
very filling it's more like a meal more
than an appetizer out of ten i would
give this maybe
a six i give um nine
all right i get the last part mmm
crunchy and i enjoy it i think i'm ready
for the next lump yeah dip is in there
oh wow
and then
so crunchy and dry
[Laughter]
nasty
it's all wrapper i think when she rolled
the lumpia it's not really secured on
both ends it's so greasy and dry at the
same time it tastes ugly and some edges
are not secured there are parts like the
other side is burnt the other side is
not
which means it wasn't really flipped
make sure next time it should be filled
up to the end sometimes it's uh too much
currency that it will break it easily
and break it apart and then you can
actually taste because it's go all over
your
blouse
excuse me
see i even choked because of too much
crunchy the other one is neutral but
this one is already salty i cannot add
more maybe he's in a hurry
he put lots of salt
mine is way better for sure i'll give it
a four oh i just rate it as a five
okay let's try the next one wow these
are huge
you know just by looking at it i'm
already full for me it looks more like a
torrent that lump
is served as a cocktail or an appetizer
or an hors d'oeuvre and not a vayant or
an ulam so it should be smaller
and a little bit of a crisp that's good
all meat
and dry there's a lot of filling
which is good but not a lot of flavor it
also made it big i would rather cut it
in half i don't see much ingredients i
didn't taste it should be balanced
shouldn't really just be the meat if you
really have a good lumpia you don't
really need the sauce and even if i dip
it here it's still ugly the sauce will
just cover up the ugliness of this we'll
try it with the dressing now
i like it better because the sauce gives
it the flavor maybe that's why she made
it like more plain would you try this at
a filipino party if it was served to you
i'm just going to bring my own
would i serve this to my kids probably
not because it's too big the sauce is
good the olympia itself
maybe a five
but together
they can be
a six
but i'm gonna give it a three for the
effort
[Music]
i want
so i put it in the cooler
so
it doesn't get soggy
this is the best numpy and it's my
lumpia
[Music]
you